what a bizarre coincidence Pat just
hours before the inauguration of Donald
Trump we hear conflicting statements
through different representatives of
Julian Assange that the WikiLeaks leader
might be willing to be extradited to the
United States Wow what could possibly be
the connection here between the leader
of WikiLeaks being willing to go to the
United States to face charges charges
that don't yet exist publicly and Donald
Trump being inaugurated I'm having
trouble thinking of what that could be
all right rush I forgot about that
Julian Assange has been in the
Ecuadorian embassy since 2012 claiming
asylum he's repeatedly said he fears
extradition to the US on espionage
charges if you leave the embassy
although again currently the only
publicly known extradition ruling
against Tim is from Sweden about a week
ago he sent the following tweet about
his extradition in connection with
chelsea manning being granted clemency
quote if obama grant manning clemency
Assange will agree to US extradition
despite clear unconstitutionality of the
Department of Justice case he hasn't
followed up but Melinda Taylor from his
legal team said he stands by what he
said quote everything that he has said
he's standing by leading some to think
that maybe Julian Assange is getting
ready for extradition the WikiLeaks
Twitter account also suggested that he
might be ready to go to the US they send
out a message saying okay this is that
same message oh here it is Assange is
confident of winning any fair trial in
the US Obama's Department of Justice
prevented Public Interest defense and
fair jury however and this is where it
starts to get complex there isn't
unanimous reporting about this because
there's an article in the hill and also
in a few other publications saying
actually this commutation of chelsea
manning sentence doesn't meet Julian
Assange's requirement to be willing to
be extradited a quote from Assange's
us-based attorney via email Barry
[ __ ] mr. Assange welcomes the
announcement that ms Manning
sentence will be reduced and she will be
released in May but this is well short
of what he sought implying no
extradition won't happen who do we know
I mean I think we just have no idea what
the truth is at this point who's right
about his position today we really don't
know and he's also just a very
interesting character for politicians to
try to pin down yeah because when the
Chelsea Manning drone strike leaks came
out liberals were all in support of them
but people like the neo-cons and the
Obama administration was against him and
now the script has kind of flipped where
you have people like Sean Hannity Donald
Trump praising him so it is really it's
really hard to pin down the White House
insists that there's no connection at
all between the commuting of Chelsea
Manning sentence and anything about what
Julian Assange might be willing to do
they insisted that the offer to be
extradited did not influence President
Obama's decision to commute Chelsea
Manning sentence so what would any
reasonable person assume was going on
here it really doesn't have much to do
with Chelsea Manning specifically
President Obama has done his pardons
he's done his commuting of sentences etc
Donald Trump will be inaugurated
tomorrow and therefore the decision in
the future about whether to charge or
officially seek to extradite Julian
Assange will fall on none other than our
orange fearless leader Donald J Trump we
now know through the consensus of
numerous intelligence agencies and based
on everything we've been talking about
for weeks months now even that Russia
through WikiLeaks helped to influence
the American election in favour of
Donald Trump we also suspect that even
if not everything in the rush of
blackmail file about Trump is true that
more than likely Russia has at least
some leverage over Trump what better
time tap to face extradition to the US
if you were Julian Assange then when the
guy your organization helped to elect
takes power sort of obvious isn't it and
it could be as soon as the day that he
takes office to once that happens it's
all fair game right yeah Julian Assange
is almost ready on January nineteenth to
face extradition maybe just a few hours
longer but he's really close to ready
total coincidence by the way the Trump
isn't
tomorrow it's also by the way legally
ambiguous how this would even work
because number one as I mentioned
there's no public extradition order for
Julian Assange to the united states that
we know of public is the key word the UK
might have their first sort of legal
dibs on Assange for jumping bail since
when he steps outside of the Ecuadorian
embassy he would immediately be in the
UK and then we know about the Sweden
sexual assault charges with whatever you
believe about their validity they do
exist in those predate of any future
public extradition order from the United
States what's the truth here conflicting
reports from different representatives
of Julian Assange I guess we don't know
we'll have to wait and see and hopefully
we will find out very very soon